another form of an op-amp circuit is
called the summing op-amp we're going to
work through how this one works
what's drawn here now is an inverting
op-amp circuit with a single input
we're going to call this this will be v
we'll call this a for now
and we have v out
and we worked out what how this worked
before
where v out was a function of v
a
times the ratio of these two resistors
and now i'm going to add a little twist
to this and we're going to analyze a
different kind of circuit so i'm going
to add another resistor right here
like this
and a second input we'll call this vb
and so we'll have rb or sorry ra here
this will be rb
and we'll call this r feedback
and the question again is now what is v
out in terms of
the inputs va and vb
we're going to use the idea of a virtual
ground
virtual ground
the idea of a virtual ground applies to
most op-amp circuits and it's a really
useful way to simplify the analysis
and when we use a virtual ground one of
the things i like to do is just draw a
little symbol here
like that for my virtual ground the
virtual ground as a review
if the voltage coming out of this op amp
is in a reasonable range sort of you
know plus or minus 10 volts or something
like that
and because the gain of this op-amp is
so enormous on the order of 100 000 or a
million
that means that when this is working
properly that
these two voltages will be really close
together
they'll be only microvolts apart at most
and because they're so close we can just
say let's just say they're the same for
the purposes of analyzing this circuit
and since this input is at zero volts
this is at zero volts that means that
this input is very close to zero volts
so this node here this node here we say
is at a virtual ground
so let's move ahead let's analyze this
circuit and what we want to find is we
want to find
v out as a function of
va
and vb
let's see if we can do that
so looking at my circuit the other thing
i know about op-amps that's really
important always is that the current
going into an op-amp input is zero or
practically zero and for the purposes of
what we're doing here
we can treat it as zero
right
so
we have zero volts on this node we have
zero current going this way so let's go
after
let's go after this current right here
let's figure out what that is so we'll
call that i
and we can express i in terms of va
and vb and these two resistor values
so we can write i
equals now what is it well we have
i a here
and we have i
b flowing here
that means that i equals ia
plus ib
right
and let me write i a and ib in terms of
ohm's law here so we get i
equals what is i a i a is
this voltage
divided by r a and this voltage is v a
minus
0 volts
so it's
va
over ra
and now let's write down what what's ib
ib
we look at this voltage here
this voltage is vb
minus
0 or just plane
vb
over rb
all right so
that's one step we've written this
current in terms of what's going on on
the input side over here
now one thing we know because this
current is zero we know what we know
this current is i
and if i is going into rf we'll label
the voltage on rf like that
so now let's write an expression for i
in terms of rf and this voltage here
what is this voltage here well let's
look at the two ends this is zero volts
on this node here
and on this side it's
v out
so the current there the current on that
side
equals
it's 0 minus v out so minus v out
divided by rf
that's ohm's law for this resistor right
here
now we know that this current equals
this current so let's just set these two
expressions together so i'll do that
over here
i can write minus v out
over r f
equals let's look this one
v a over r a
plus
v b
over rb
now we can get the final function i'm
just going to multiply through by rf on
both sides
and we get
v out
equals take the minus sign with us minus
rf
over ra
times va
plus
rf
over
rb
times v b
so that's our answer that's v out as a
function of
v a and v b the two inputs
and you can see that the resistor ratio
there's two resistor ratios here that
are participating in the answer
so it helps to do a little special case
of this let's let all the resistors be
the same so we'll say that r a
equals rb
equals rf
and
just to pick a real number we'll just
say they're all equal to 10k
ohms
and let's see what this becomes now now
we have v out
equals we still have the negative sign
so this is some sort of inversion going
on here rf over ra is one so it's just
va
and
rf over rb
is one so this says
vb
so this is what gives us the nickname
for this expression which is called a
a summing
op-amp
let's say i want to use my summing op
amp in a in an application where what i
want is i want v out to equal
say
minus 2 times va
plus
3 times vb
okay this is what i want how do i do
that
so these two coefficients here are
functions of the resistor values that
was our original expression up here
so what i want is
r f
over r a
to equal 2
and i want r
f
over rb
to equal
three
so i can pick values it's the same rf
and so i get to adjust our a and rb in
here so i can pick component values if i
pick
r f
equals 12 k ohms
then i can pick
our a
equals 6k
and rb
equals
4k
and that would give me the ratios i want
and that would implement
this function here so i'm going to go
fill those out on the top schematic
we'll just write those in
and we'll go fill these in here so what
we said was rf was 12k
ra
was 6k ohms
rb would be
4 kms
and we've designed a circuit that
implements our summing function
so so this is a pretty useful op-amp
circuit